i've been warning you about today for
months
july 30th the day that we knew we would
get our estimate of the second quarter
gdp number of the united states
we received that number this morning and
it is historic it's historically bad
i mean why did donald trump tweet today
that he wants to delay the election i
believe that the gdp number is part of
it
in addition to the collapsing polls the
united states economy
shrank by the biggest amount on record
in the second quarter this year
annualized
second quarter gdp was down
32.9 percent
32 point the economy contracted
annualized by roughly a third in the
second quarter
now the expectation was to to be down 34
so being down 33 is like slightly less
bad than the expectation
but a historic disastrous number now
we know why it's very easy to say listen
it's not trump's fault it's coronavirus
okay but the trump administration has
failed
in terms of the coronavirus response so
the health numbers meaning cases
and deaths are worse than the numbers
had to be just look at other countries
and the economic numbers are also worse
than they had to be
the big areas of reduction in gdp were
not shockingly consumer spending in the
personal consumption category
and remember that this is just an
estimate we get more precise numbers
about another month out
so this is an estimate on july 30th
we're expecting the
sort of more more fine-tuned numbers
right around august 30th and
who knows what will be going on by then
with coronavirus now meanwhile new
jobless claims
have also gone in the wrong direction
new jobless claims
are up for the second week in a row to
1.43
million new claims this is the 19th
straight week with more than one million
people
losing their jobs of the 19 weeks
new jobless claims it was like 6.6
million that first
week or the second week and then they've
been declining for 15 weeks
now things have turned around and new
jobless claims have started to increase
and the unfortunate reality is that it
could get much worse
if states have to continue pulling back
if we continue to see
cases rise deaths have spiked and we'll
talk about that next
i believe states are going to have to
pull back and
the numbers are going to once again get
worse we were we were told in april may
by june 1st june 15th there will be very
few new cases and barely any deaths
there will be a break between wave one
and what is expected to be a second wave
in the fall
we're not getting that break we are
actually when we got down to 20 000 new
cases a day
things started opening irresponsibly in
some states more responsibly in others
and we are now seeing the effects of
that and the next thing i want to talk
about is the numbers
and the trajectory that these numbers
could very soon take
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they are giving my audience
25 off your first order
this has been a game changer for me this
is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way
of getting yourself rehydrated and it
tastes
awesome there's a variety of flavors i
have blood orange which i love
you can also get grapefruit and lime a
lot of us don't even realize
when we're dehydrated a lot of the time
and it's become a really uh great part
of my daily routine
if i'm under hydrated i'm affected
physically
i'm affected mentally and i think you
never fully understand this
until you use hydrant for the first time
i get a great
uh a boost of energy when i'm properly
hydrated if i've been dehydrated
they also have a version with caffeine
which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video